well care in the in the studio by german you
see filmmaker and behind
so a technology documents that play
2 rocks
your video my ear that in a film gold
hair war my journey to john inside of
a warm welcome
well in 2014 at this very dark time  in a
history of your people you decide to
good iraq with your father
this is just it explore your ancestral
bootz by going to the je citroen web and
then of course the eyes
john side words on the style your
community
we nu stil decided to go where  i was already
it felt like this to see the pictures to d5
you are like death and the site in the
beginning in a very painful just like baby
dark week before war yezidis in the
word and service well had a fourteen
when that happened to my people  know
man was interested in the area janice
site in this was what to offer where you
have so dead am i heard fact he
was in you see ie total of jessie the
refugees who left the country house of
child with a and
defective have the iboard  jaune so oh  m die
to the site frost be to go da
en to make je document shui of my
light wat
babysite man so it was appear life
changing moment anglaise show list and
came back so you might activist
but this was null ada joystick rose many
people week flying  and king who in it
was like janice to creation no
but when world is not interested in bed
was to be wire wind and am very
interested in canada tension de you de
each know the skype and it like you go
moar and chewie
say you  wanna documents professional
is comin' on that are the same
time the therapy pedal also like you
sound like you a grab your community
for one on one te picture for as what
did you find again new right there and
find hong kong janice naar de people  who
it 4s all home with it and it will
be peak fighters
and of course there was a lot of fell
at my the deep web was king call
it in the moment almost was da to your nfl
with everything new and home will keeper
well just  approx  me back
mikado of this signal mountains and
there be woners wondering if was
seen in politics pictures in this and
download a tent or grass is getting thick
through the people
yes corpse shocked out of being shocked to
day en dit was my not able to  speak
network rising
and the word seems to be the woman but what is
round and what is happening
beep twice and at that time
many many people in ipad captivity
anyway the gold of the wim and how he
in fine oats had to touch
and just  good names of the cities we
also seems what ailment you what is
happening here and this at that time it
was one of the most dangerous place i
was the word chair week avda
james foley being that header and my
mother was came he went and was like  my
drunk we just dead he na at
pt is the city and the john allison
before fierce your bed and towers baby
women time my father no whitney what
of the beginning thing am who will the
refugees though
students in the valley of a  situation
and iin test any more about my own free
links i was there is going to be a happening
oncology tennis naomi build up warns m in
or permission is it going to be gaping you the
yezidis is is america his on
and dragging me ass
torture you're taking and gaping  u de you
see the community by s there is a wind
sorry des tourelles for you he
restless to think about jamin and jamin
was joost is it site soda interviews and
they individual magic who in the videos
of irons and wedges hypocrisy that and
for i a  bit of the speak so color
pendulum swings anymore and
bed sometimes time moment pi cost for time
after which not him
you have to sleep but the list heim there
was no life anymore in this and
and between him will
and and plens and siebelinks bos bij wie
even before bukowski was a tweeting seem
old then he was sitting de loon and
ajax mass
beam it will be thinking and i thought to
you want to go to my husband and astrology
less that this someone
bartiméus idols ma  one of us and that one becomes
again orchestra hawking english and
testing is one of many many eczema put
becomes that it means to be in the hands of
a is so that one is or you is some muscles that
becomes in that gent in the mire da
between
the  lights and they came back what i need
good full of god but it is happening to
them  berries identity and i'm
thinking it's freezing
well here are ferocious situation lie
kwie cinemas got inside cover
art
evans is bing search what is had left
digicity community candy go bike
y'all be a pic here billy bass no way
to go back en dan  home most value 5
yes go in and it's like this life
changing trees
wel foil was i hear more just talking
about my mechanic
and 500 keeping in this reads and those on
the wall other thing in diaspora and the
levy in refugee he who geek men  s so
might know that no way be turned back to
their homeland
i'll go if need be i siemens has he that
's how the yezidis live is you the justice
or evil push the girl or the janice
out of it as if the driveway unity to go back
to the homeland
i  hear just have nothing to do what
roots nourishments nike creams and he sings
the big difference of this file toe
adam became quarrels is via drew built in
and janice site and this is what is in den
neck bc hats stave bio hungry wat
rest die or biervliet format  assink
again pulled out a boat and janice and
destil about something like a flower and
koopa mist and dso people haven't always shrunk
yezidis
and of course they don't speak english
place to stand
but everyone knows what knowledge site means
and that means is it quiet in  that time
demon jazz justice and nothing in between to
offer especially what wider mine
to get out and seek out what was
happening to them in this something
which is not works super cool for wim
in how has in week is a web e  n of
wall and testing carpet where you see the
people
especialy pushing my you between boys
means that is the only choice to get out
and therefore be is a and gio it is
a born out of the essence of
knowledge site
wiggle fighting and column for so
within  and what be found him for this to
make you get the enemy soviets the
people all the enemies of war was so
pulled porter ministation and jenn the
site must be something which they can
clot in europe and therefore it is
not just for things that deep it  preserve
unity
elisabeth marie none become a bark is
so striking is i slept you mentioned is
the strengt de je see the women watches
beyond my spine and an action en
rebuilding recognition describe the time
of scrooge the tape the crack
chip number turning of cross and doe ik
if necessary was a that area around lid and
dr who
toe man and who we have my impala
with center in ai work for my hand
with him in jetty this moment with or
without him a little kiss who w  ant to go back
to life be and with empowerment
programs was with each programs 2
beds that do it with minister and
existence doktor get nu la cour divorce
al keys and mia very happy or so who
is your see the woman who was born in
already in germany
epi already drew what are and that biset who
has then who really and who has to the
day the coasters i don't eat a piano
talking about changing thumping who
closure for existence so a take
a la fere way series here film i drove
ducks so  much less you all the
best you have to fancy there you think